meanwhile parades are back for saint
patty's station it's going to be fun the
professional firefighters of nevada
they're back with their annual parade
and games in downtown las vegas and
that's where our own bianca holman is
this morning to tell us more about it
what else is going on down there today
bianca
hey good morning jerry good morning good
morning everybody at home happy st
patrick's day so the parade is back here
in downtown las vegas starting at
fremont and maine and ending right here
in front of hogs and heifer saloon
popular spot in here downtown and
there's going to be the firefighters
game so if you're not familiar this
parade has been going on for a while
it's finally a tradition that has
returned after two years so the focus is
of course to celebrate st patrick's day
but also to raise money for the
professional firefighters of nevada
donations it's just a way to pay it
forward you never know when you'll need
the firefighters to save you or a loved
one this group provides services to
firefighters families if their
firefighter is killed or has died during
service and it's the brotherhood and
sisterhood that camaraderie that keeps
firefighters so dedicated
guys and gals i work with is
extraordinary to go home have my wife
and kids at home and then to go to work
and have my my brothers you know guys
who are older than me that i look up to
as a father figure and always having
someone to rely on so that family
atmosphere is one of the best feelings
in the world
so here's the rundown of today's event
the parade begins at noon it starts at
fremont maine to the fremont experience
3rd street left heading northern and
north and ends at hogs and heifer saloon
and then at one o'clock the firefighters
games kick off and coming up in the next
half hour we're going to talk with the
folks here at haunts and heifers about
what it means to them to contribute to
such a great calls and of course for the
parade to be back back to you guys in
the studio all right bianca thanks so
much boy those pictures look so fun of
all the firefighter games